on a regardé un peu ce qui se faisait
sur le marché réunionnais avec des
spectacles des fois 64 euros ou 37 euros
en tous les cas rarement quelque chose
en dessous de 25 et on s'est aperçu que
nous on était encore un prix moyen 28
euros pour plus de 15 groupes par soir
donc économiquement on y arrive plus
alors ça c'est le prix moyen d'avant 28
€ et là le prix moyen aujourd'hui là on
devrait on a pris 10 euros le prend je
pense que le prix moyen va se situer
entre 35 et 38 euros et moi cher c'était
pas possible moins cher c'est plus
possible pour nous
on a maintenu la politique tarifaire
pendant très longtemps et c'est
absolument impossible il faudrait
trouver beaucoup d'autres choses alors
après à côté de ça on développe tout un
tas d'opérations avec des partenaires
sur des publics cibles on va dire un peu
plus en difficulté donc avec qui on mène
des opérations et on essaie de faire en
sorte que le prix soit moins impactant
un calcul vous pensez je pense au public
de proximité sur le quartier de la
Ravine Blanche avec le soutien de la
schlmr par exemple
je pense à voilà il y a aussi des
nouveautés c'est à dire que par exemple
il y a le Pass Culture qui permet aux
jeunes
de d'avoir un financement pour pour leur
place de concert il y a un certain
dispositif du gouvernement tout à fait
donc voilà il y a tout un tas de choses
et on voit qu'on a de plus en plus de
billets achetés via le Pass Culture
notamment sur la soirée de samedi par
exemple avec des artistes vendredi ou
samedi que les jeunes attendent
particulièrement donc
je pense qu'il y a aussi encore pas mal
de réflexion à avoir là dessus sur te
dire que mieux cibler des tarifs pour
des publics plus en difficulté je pense
que c'est un peu l'avenir
après pour le reste il nous faut avoir
soit beaucoup plus de soutien pour
compenser les choses soit trouver une
nouvelle économie on a fait ce choix là
pour l'instant et on verra pour la suite